欢迎回来赵花
欢迎说
你在看电影或漫画的时候
你会不会从中
就悟到了一些投资的心得
或是那个内容
特别吸引你
我从这个兴趣
打麻将学的也蛮多的
对
因为其实他们都是一样的东西
你要有纪律
气不好不要出手
对不对
气好要乘胜追击
其实是有一点道理
我是看电影的时候
真的特别喜欢
裡面有關於財經的竅端
像最近Netflix有重新
把一個老的片上架
叫刺激1995
我本來以為那是一個冤獄的片
結果裡面的那一個主角
也是有財經的頭腦
對 還有像之前什麼華爾街之狼
大麥控 好看
對 華爾街之狼不是所有
少年股神的夢想嗎
其實我這禮拜才要講華爾街之狼
我自己的頻道
突然
好 所以今天呢
我們的來賓
他就是以前从看电影
开始有一些对投资的想象
而且他会帮你把脉
我们先来欢迎他
就是骨科大夫 龙医生Eason
主持人好 观众朋友大家好
我是骨科大夫Eason
Eason第一次来上我们的
《照话爱人说》
我们今天要把你的身家
把你起底没有
起底
因为骨科大夫他叫大夫
所以叫做人心良树
妙手回春
怎么样会有取这个绰号
這個名字的想像呢
就是我現在週二
都有固定在節目
幫投資朋友解盤
每一次大概100多個問題
見證是不是
對 問問題
都問免費的
對 今天晚上又有
好 今天晚上就有嗎
對
先看我們再去問
對 8點鐘開始
就每個禮拜大概
都有100多個問題
以上
那就是一年下來
其實我看很多
大概散務朋友同比
大概就是賺得抱不住
賠得砍不掉
盤整盤一直上下刷洗
然後呢
真正大趨勢都沒有跟得住
大概問題就那幾個
所以投資朋友
你如果我大概看你
三四個月對帳單
我就知道說你問題
可能會出在哪裡
對 所以就是
那時候一直幫大家見證
一開始我還每天
然後後來就是
實在是真的
負荷量太大了
所以就變成每週一次
後來就是
補合大夫
那其中有個原因是
因為那時候YouTube
剛開始要做頻道
然後這個在想說
到底要取個什麼名字呢
那時候有一個
YouTube很紅
叫理科太太
對
然后想说取个谐音
骨科大夫好像不错
对 好
我知道了
那你帮我看一下好不好
这是我这三四个月的对账单
是不是应该就直接见诊
好 所以是有这样一个前提
好 有兴趣的朋友
看完理财单就再去见诊好不好
你跟我们电视播出的时间达到了
但是帮别人治病之前
其实骨科大夫以前
也有过很茫然的时候
对 因为刚毕业不知道做什么
然后那时候
大家知道我念資管
一開始有當過工程師
也有當PM
然後後來覺得資管好像
就是工程師
我們跟妳有句話就是說
城市寫得好 要飯要到老
就是你看現在其實寫真是
都可以被Anthorpeak
被很多AI取代
對 我那時候其實就是覺得說
做這件事情好像有點浪費時間
我那時候有個同事
就是寫每一段城市很厲害
寫Excel 寫VBA很厲害
然後我就想說我到底要不要花
還要去進修
然後花時間去弄這些程式
我想說以後應該會不會就有
電腦可以取代
結果果然在2025、2026開始
就是越來越大量的AI去取代了
後來其實當完在軟體公司之後
那又去當很多
做自己興趣的事情
譬如當過職業魔術師
當過一年
職業的魔術師
你還不是在達人手表演魔術而已
對 我有當過職業
職業魔術師是
那種什麼各個場子表演
然後收費那一種
對 一場可能大概幾千塊這樣
小友 行親戚
那時候就是名氣不大的
大概就幾千塊這樣子
因為也過得蠻辛苦的
後來就想說
是不是要找一些這個什麼方式
可以去讓自己收入更多一些些
然後其實對股票就蠻有興趣的
因為我去大學就是賣股票
那時候可能就是
當作固定存錢
然後也不知道
什麼去正確的去學習
就亂買
那個時候其實我們
學習管道很封閉
就是可能都聽消息
電視上面可能也是
就是投顧老師
其實從小
我們家裡我爸媽
也有在做股票
我就看到我媽
我每天回到就看到
那時候投顧老師都很激動
每天都講口莫焚黑
然後我沒回到家
就看到他看那個
然後我爸也是有買股票
然後覺得這個好像很神奇
一買一賣
按一下按鈕好像就有錢進來
那後來真的進入市場之後
發現根本不是這麼一回事
就其實學問水很深的
那後來就一直去做研究
那我剛出社會的時候
其實這個還
就是去學一些投資理財
然後認識一些朋友
然後結果有朋友跟我說
我介紹你一個商品
固定領席的
然後每一年大概就8% 9%
而且一單位要這個
五萬十萬美金起跳
大家有沒有聽起來很熟悉
怎麼這兩年有發生過啊
你有沒有聽到這種
類似的話術的話
那我跟你講你要
這個全身的神經要緊繃起來
因為這種固定配息
然後感覺好像很安全
尤其是錢又回到國外的話
那我當時就是中了這個招了
因為當時其實剛入行
然後沒有什麼研究
然後就想說好像穩定配息不錯
那它也不是那種暴力
也不是一年十幾二十%
我就想說就用這個房子去借了
15萬美金就投進去了
那一開始一兩年
還有穩定的一個配型
後來就拿不回來了
就其實現在反詐騙很多
我們當時也是環境很封閉
大概15 16年前
那所以當時就是這個
算是對當時的資金
還不小的一個衝擊
那所以後來也就開始認真的研究股票
然後認真的去學一些技術
學一些籌碼等等的
學一些這個產業的訊息
好 你不要看現在的資訊很發達
這一套就是說
你要有10萬美元才能投
然後年息大概9% 10%
到現在我都還有朋友上當
還是有嗎
這一套真的歷久不出來
從馬多夫以前那時候193幾年那是最開始那個叫龐氏騙局他就是基本上後金補錢金所以我覺得現在大家可能都有詐騙的這個觀念是比較多的
我覺得大家一定要去注意
這個血和錢不要
隨隨便便的就交出去
重點是不要投資
自己不懂的東西
是 好 後來你就變成
很用功的在學習對不對
而且剛剛也特別聊到
你可能有很多種學習方式
像你自己會自己畫
每天的K棒之外
你看電影都會想到
怎麼樣做投資
對 好 那這個K棒是我
就是後來下定決心自己學習之後
然後跟這個一個
雖然以前老一輩的主力大戶
就每天跟他在VIP室裡面研究
然後他就教我
你要練盤桿是不是
你就畫這種圖圈
我今天有帶來
好 今天有帶來
股科畫了非常久的一段時間
哇塞 等一下
這是什麼
這個是 每一天畫一根K棒是不是
每一貼嗎
他是用價格去做
每一貼在方格子上畫
這個我只有聽過
我還沒
等一下這有點多
艾倫幫忙捲一下
這可能捲到門口
那個攝影大哥幫忙拿一下
對
這可能捲到門口
其實很長
反正就是
這幾天的
這個應該畫了有大概兩年吧
這是兩萬元
家裡還有更長
就一直畫畫到去年沒有在畫
因為畫到都老花眼了
畫15分鐘眼睛就痛了
你可以叫AI畫
所以就每天畫一根K棒
價格有到
它是沒有
不是看時間的
它是看價格
就是價格有達到就畫一根這樣子
價格有達到就
轉折線
對
好 每天這樣畫
從這畫多久 十幾年
我從 對 應該有十幾年
十幾年
從剛開始
非常用功地畫
對 那時候就每天還看
股票看十幾個小時
是 每天看十幾個小時
難怪眼睛不舒服
眼睛都畫到不舒服了
很用功耶
你有畫過嗎
有
你有畫過
你有這麼用功
有
那個時候
那時候其實那一套蠻流行的
是
找聖杯啊
你可以K棒啊
給你四個價格
是
然後你就透過這四個價格
畫K棒
然後去感受它那個漲跌
有什麼樣的依據
是
鍊盤感
那你現在還有在畫嗎
沒有啊
他沒有啊
對啊
Eason可以坚持到前一年嘛
是
好像十年 十幾年前就沒話了
那你沒有坚持過啊
這個是很用功的一個證明
對 這個是練盤感
然後就是讓自己更熟悉盤面的脈動
那其實找一些題材
我會看電影或打電玩裡面
其實都很多未來的題材
像我們以前小時候有那個
那個叫什麼
霹靂車李麥克這樣是不是
那個就是 影集啊
對 手錶按一按
車子就會跑過來
是
所以那個時候我們小時候
電視也不多
那時候就很有印象
電動車嘛
是特斯拉
對 當特斯拉出來的時候
我們就知道說
這個東西不一樣了
那特斯拉當時呢
這個真正開始有突破是在2019年
那時候他突破量產地域
開始可以順利的量產
然後呢他在上海
有這個超級工廠出來
那更是關鍵
後來搭配到了疫情
無限QE讓整個資金
這種比較高本益比高成長類股
去做一個比較偏投機的
這樣一個熱度交易
然後到了2021年
他也是全球電動車銷量的冠軍
那那個時候他佔全球新車一層
全球其實非常多的廠牌
光是車廠就佔一層
那他這一波2019到2021
大概總共上漲了34倍
那我當中其實也吃到一個
不小的波段
對 所以其實這種科技上市
如果又是新的
領先的科技
我覺得大家都可以去多注意一下
後來就是在輝達
開始2023年爆紅
輝達我們以前有在組電腦
它的一個顯卡都是最高端的
最高級的
你要打電動
然後要一個就是畫面要最漂亮
然後幀數要最快
那一定要用輝達的顯卡
那就在2023年
TrackGPT開始爆紅
我那時候就覺得這個東西
跟以前的電腦不一樣
因為我們以前
不管你用Windows
這個Win95
到98到2000
到Windows 7、80
Windows再怎麼進化
它一樣是input
計算之後output
就只是畫面漂亮一些些
然後算得更快一些些
那處理的方式其實是完全一樣
可是在聊天機器人出來之後
我就覺得這東西不一樣
因為AI其實可以
未來可以像這樣代理式的這樣成長
那後來當然故事大家都知道
AI伺服器
GB系列
BlackWave放量
然後包括它的業績持續的成長
那甚至還有未來的主權AI
還像現在的這個代理人的AI
所以AI在當年2023到2025
也這個上漲14倍
那我同樣的當中也賺了不少的這個倍數
所以我覺得在目前來說的話
我們先看
當時特斯拉就是
不管是他在這個獲利創新高
上海廠交車以及在納入S&P500
那他的這個波段下跌
這一段它也跌了75%
真的很誇張
因為它一直沒有很明確的獲利
剛開始
對 那這一段就是
它在這個暴力升息過後
很多高本益比股下修
可是你看這種
即使它的
這個很多可能還是靠補助
或者是它的這個股價
大幅度拉回之後
其實後面還是創新高了
到後來它跟川普
麻吉麻吉的時候
這股價還是回到歷史新高
所以我覺得這種科技類股
像其實META之前暴跌過
真的有這種暴跌的時候
只要它的這個產業
沒有太特別變化的話
我覺得大家你是可以把一些這種
閒錢去做這種長線的投資
因為美股的波段
常常跑得比台股還要來得更久
那全球的這種科技業
其實主要還是看美股的臉色
那在輝達的話也是
它其實當中不管是這個營收炸裂
Blindwell登場
它一拆時過等等的
那它在關稅那個時間點
也掉了四成
股價最高點
這個幾乎快要腰斬
可是呢到後來它是首家突破
5兆美元市值的這個公司
那我認為其實現在輝達
因為已經市值越來越高了
所以它的一個爆發性可能不如以往
所以我現在呢又
這個開始關注一個新的題材
就是SpaceX
太空題材的這個電影
大家有看過嗎
好 我覺得你真的也算是馬斯克的信眾之一了特斯拉買的真的叫做一個信仰那當然跟車子相關的未來性的電影很多太空的也很多啊對啊 對
所以大家可能可以預料到
未來可能會
可以飛到月球去啊
月球已經是小case了
對 火星會不會殖民啊
是
以及太空AI等等的
那不管是Space
它這個
這個衛星準備越發越多了
然後包括它的這個筷子
把火箭夾回來
那個絕對是
讓成本大幅度下降
然後讓未來這個火箭發射
可以商轉重要的一個因素
那包括其實未來手機的一個
直接聯網
這個對於
電信營運商可能就要
是不是有些衝擊
包括各國也要開放
在烏二戰爭之後
這個地圍道衛星
開始大家
逐漸注意到它的一個重要性
那太空AI部分我覺得
可能是在更遠一些些
就是
說要在這個衛星軌道上面
計算之後再傳回來
那我覺得這個可能是
比較長期
那我覺得短期可以看到
這也是在跟各個軍用的這個部分
有持續性的這樣收入
以及在手機的這個聯網的部分
那台灣不知道什麼時候也可以
有這樣子的低軌道微信
等於五角落
那全
甚至在飛機上面
都可以實際有這樣子的網路
所以接下來我覺得可以去注意一下
今年非常多的低軌道微信題材
像是在 Amazon
也要這個正式去做一個啟用
以及在歐洲的 OneWeb等等的一個擴建
但是这样的题材
它有时候跟获利不见得
能够马上联动在一起
所以它非常仰赖着
就是你很相信
在一个很长线
在你的有生之年
这件事情它会被实践
对不对
对 我觉得
就大家的资金也是有限的
然后注意力也是有限的
是 注意力有限
对 真的注意力有限
每天花这么多的一个端银
或是很多这样
会让我分心的事情
我觉得现在都要尽量
把注意力集中
专注在特定的产业
或是特定的事情上面
那低伪道卫星
當然台股的代表之一就是
申達科
目前可以看到
最近籌碼面都不錯
投信也在低檔做一個加碼
那8月的支撐
大概就在這個地方
等一下我們後面會講
一個賺賠比的概念
它這個地方就是賺賠比
還不錯的概念
往下的風險可能只有一些些
那在5到7月
它為什麼拉回這麼多呢
主要是因為它的客戶的設計調整
好像之前AI有調整過軍熱片
或是什麼CPU規格調整等等
之類這種類似的題材
那它是真的受到客戶影響
所以營收看起來有些掉下來
可是8月已經復活了
8月份開始
月增40%
年增93%
那包括今年來說的話
它地軌道衛星的比重
會提升到77%
所以等於說它
完全就是跟地軌道衛星掛鉤了
所以估計明年EPS
應該可以來到37塊
後年就可以來到62塊
所以我覺得這個位置
已經開始有法人認為
是有吸引力的位置
所以我認為這個地方
即使不是最低也不遠了
但是大家可能就要有耐心一些
因為它跟SpaceX
跟地圍繞星會是相對的連動
那我覺得後續看
在它有沒有切入到其他歐洲
其他的這樣子一個衛星的題材
好 如果說今天像這種SpaceX
它可以開始重新往上走的時候
可能大家的本夢比空間
就比較有機會拉出來了對不對
因為現在美股跟台股
剛好我們錄影的今天
都是一個比較悶盤的狀況
所以就等這個
所謂的本夢比
再次的把它拉開來
對 我覺得投資
很重要的一個
我覺得我自己認為的
一個概念就是
你要去知道說
你進場的風險在哪裡
然後你賺賠比怎麼樣
風暴比怎麼樣
所以我覺得
你想要有這樣子的獲利
你一定要達到這樣大賺
小賠的一個模式
就是賠的時候
可能賠一點點
但賺的時候
盡量有一個大的
這樣子一個波段
或大的一個空間
我今天剛好有帶
我的新書來
你的新書
你也有新書
對 這個技術班的書
送給兩位主持人
哎呀
對
哎呦 等一下
接骨特訓班
我們今天要幫
谷科Take的東西相當多
接骨
接骨就是骨頭斷掉的話
要把它接起來的意思
對啊 接骨
谷科大夫的
接骨特訓班
剛剛好像有無意間聽到
這一本
就是要2萬8
這一本要2萬8
那我們要回送
回送股科是什麼
對
就是今天晚上8點
請你幫我見證
沒問題
好 謝謝股科大夫
肌股特訓班全採的
對 全採的
我剛看了一眼
我們現在要來把它飆售嗎
把這個今天的錢賺回來
對 我只有講裡面的幾個觀念
所以這裡面也有
梳理局面
對 這個是梳理面的PPT
那就是賺賠比
大家進場的時候
你就要先去想一下
我這一單的風險在哪裡
那進場的
進場的這個停損就要先設定好
停損也要先設定好
怎麼弄呢
因為這樣子你才會有一個
長期可以標準化的一個方式
就是你每一次進場的邏輯要一樣
你如果一下子看技術
一下子就看籌碼
一下子聽名牌
一下這個一下那個
你的進場的這個邏輯
你就沒有辦法把它去做一個
科學的一個標準化跟去復盤
所以你一定要每一次進場的規則
是要一致的
要有一致性
你才能夠去持續優化
你的一個這樣子一個績效
所以如果你每一次進場
都是找這種
風險可能是一單位
停損是一個單位
那獲利有辦法來到
三倍或者四倍以上的本益比
那長期下來
即使有賺賺賠賠
可是殘下來你就會是市場的贏家
在大數法則之下
你的期望值就會是正的
好 這個就是在股市當中
有的人很專注在勝率
可是我覺得這反而不是最重要的勝率
反而是你要看
這每一單的期望值是多少
那這樣子的這個狀況下
其實我覺得股市難免會來回回
像上半年行情好做
好 那最近可能就震盪整理
那我覺得資金控管這個部分
相對來的比較重要
就是在真的有行情的時候
就像剛剛艾倫講的
贏要衝啊
輸要縮
這種沒有行情就不要隨便亂動
或者是這個多看少做
我覺得都是可以的
那我覺得其實大家要注意
你盤中是不是
跟隨著自己情緒去做交易
有時候盤中會FOMO
然後不得不已去追
有時候呢又會砍在一個
相對可能阿呆股
會都砍在阿呆股
我覺得這個都是被
心裡所控制了因為超出了自己所承受的這個虧損好 我顧這幾年我這個終於悟到一件事情什麼事
就是你有沒有看過讓子彈飛這部電影
讓子彈飛
有
就是我只有吃一碗粉不是兩碗粉
最後他怎麼把那個黃色狼給殺掉
大家還記得嗎
最後他就是那個首領
他在那個村裡面這樣繞來繞去
繞來繞去
叫大家拿著槍衝進去
大家沒有人敢衝
都一直在那邊龜縮的
大家都怕
可是後來他把那個替身的黃次郎
直接把他斬了
然後把他的頭拿回來
就是告訴村民說
黃次郎已經被殺掉
大家趕快進去搶錢
結果村民全部都瘋了
都衝進去
所以大家一般散戶心態就是
就賺的時候很怕沒賺到
看到大家都在賺
隔壁也賺了
然後呢
大家都是這個賺了盆滿不滿
很怕自己也沒賺到
都要賺一筆
可是呢
叫大家這個
風險的時候去衝的時候
大家反而不太願意
反而還在觀望一下
我覺得這個大家的
就是心態我覺得
可能要稍微調整一下
不管是賺或者是賠
不要盤中隨著這個情緒在起舞
一定要有計畫
一定要去執行自己的交易的計畫
那如果要賺到一個大的波段
我認為一定要靠這樣子不斷的
停力上移
好 就是正常回檔
然後這邊要停力對不對
對 就拉回
上漲之後拉回
那再一次轉折勾起來
過高的時候
我的停力就不斷的移動
移動 停力點往上移動
對 這樣才會吃到一個大的波段
像去年記憶體
被動還有間寧低劑的CPU
都是這樣
那不要覺得說
長太多就去平常
我覺得就算平常也不要全部賣掉
手上一定要有一些部位
你才會知道說
這個到底後面的盤感
後續這個股票是如何
因為賣了可能就後面
就不會去注意到它了
所以其實就是照著紀律去走
然後搭配到我剛剛講的
這個賺賠比的條件
那就有機會抱到一個大的波段
好 不要無聊平倉
就是覺得無聊了就賣一賣
沒必要
對 或覺得
欸 漲不太動了
或覺得賺很多了
就把它平倉了
我覺得就是其實起碼到高點
那也只是做一個動作就是停力壓近
我的停力壓近一些些
但是它沒有到條件
我就是抱著
是
這樣子一個方式
好 真是一個修行
對啊
要讓情緒穩定
好 那接下來就是我覺得
在接下來第四季到明年第一季
比較有機會的兩個產業
是
CPU跟在散裝的部分
那CPU當然
我覺得現在CPU好像2023年的
AI剛開始出來一樣
因為未來傳輸速度要越來越快
所以在CPU
其實過去這幾年
這個炒過好幾波
說實在光進同退講得好糗了
可是真的終於到了
今年第四季到明年要開始量產
甚至先跨入
先用NPO的這樣子一個題材
所以在其中一檔
3450聯軍
最近大戶開始在做一個轉買
包括外資在做一個進場
那聯軍的話就可以注意一下
它的一個突破缺口的支撐在這裡
所以這個地方進場
就是賺賠比還不錯的
停損缺口就在這個地方
可是往上我覺得可以先看
前高附近的這個位置
那如果又搭配到CPU
如果是大行情的話
那其實它的賺賠比
風險只有一點點
可是往上先看這裡
那更往上也許還有更大一段
這種就是賺賠比不錯的一個位置
對 那它包括子公司
這個圓結也結合
矽光子電路製進能力
推動800G的一個產品
所以後續注意第三季的毛利率
可不可以維持
然後月營收可不可以再上
更近一個台階
CPU大部分都可以注意一下
未來這一季到下一季
應該要很明顯的有
營收獲利進來了
好 他們也是一個比較明後年
大家可以把這個做夢行情拉開
但是航運的話
不就是蠻實在的
就是要看報價嗎
對 BDI最近一直持續在漲
然後在散裝的部分
現在旺季也來臨
包括鐵礦砂
以及在這個西非等等的
這個礦石道去運送
然後還有一個
我覺得要非常注意的
就是在這個聖因現象
今年年底聖因現象發生的機率
可能高達九成以上了
我覺得這個最近大家都沒有講到
可是這個確實是
我覺得這個才是對通膨影響
比較大的一個因素
怎麼說
因為就是包括穀物
最近包括白糖 玉米 小麥等等
都開始有在漲
大概都漲了三成四成以上
那散裝的部分
最近也可以看到
籌碼開始轉加
主力在轉買 大戶轉買
然後它現在這個風暴比也不錯
風險就這一點點
往上一樣可以看
先看去年的高點
去年高點在這裡
可是大家注意起來
2021年航海網航行情它是這樣子
那這種低檔月線
剛開始起漲
而且量能如果開始出來的話
這個就很像我剛才講的農產品
或之前的記憶體
如果有行情的話
好 那如果有來大的話
這種行情才要去拚
這種不拚難道要高點去拚嗎
我覺得相對這個風險是比較低的
而且如果萬一真的有搭上大行情的時候
其實這種的賺賠比都是非常漂亮的
好 不過記憶體我印象很深
因為你是在去年就率先講記憶體的人
但是後來賺到今年
到一個程度的時候
你就比較不講記憶體了
對 你現在的看法有任何的改變嗎
還是你覺得其他的
其實剛剛講到的風險報酬比
是比較合理的
對 就是剛才那個概念來說
我覺得記憶體現在的風暴比
已經沒那麼漂亮
但是我覺得
現在看起來產業好像還沒有扎音
除了有這個
那個有就是產業高產認為說
記憶體的價格是不是漲太多了
那我覺得其實這種狀況
可能就要等到拉回比較深的時候
再去做一個低接
但是現在看起來HBM仍然是用的
用量是非常的多
那南亞科的這個股價看起來
比HBN还要更为强劲
那这个也要考虑到
未来DDR4的这个实用性是如何的
是
好那今天真的很谢谢谷柯大夫
也是第一次在这个电视萤幕前面听你讲
原来进入到投雇这一行
也有受到家庭的影响
你好像也是嘛
就大家进来这一行
都会希望能够颠覆以前的那些印象
所以用很用功的
还有一些可以规则化的法则
来设定投资逻辑对不对
希望給大家比較有好的印象